loulou autrefois mont blanc à 13 ans cet
été il partira en vacances avec sa
nouvelle famille qui l'a adopté à la spa
d'orgeval en avril dernier en plein
troisième confinement une adoption qu'on
appelle sos loulou est âgé et à quelques
soucis de santé pour autant il était
inenvisageable pour ses propriétaires de
se séparer de lui pendant leurs congés
mon mari charge la voiture tous
préparent et on amène la veille la
caisse pour qu'il s'habitue
quand c'est le moment de partir c'est le
dernier avec moi à rentrer alors moi et
lui nous sommes à l'arrière ça fait
sourire nos amis mais c'est pas grave
comme ça il est moins frustré parce
qu'il ya des chats qui aime qui aiment
pas et on n'aime pas le drogué nom comme
ça je suis à côté et avec cette nouvelle
caisse
il est attaché il à son collier et il
est attaché dans la caisse la caisse est
attaché au siège et il peut naviguer
dans le coffre
toutes ces affaires en plus des valises
du couple sans oublier la litière et la
laisse car lorsque le couple arrive sur
son lieu de vacances quelques heures
voire une journée sont nécessaires pour
que le loup s'habituer à son nouvel
environnement pour les sorties en
extérieur c'est en laisse d'abord à
chaque fois quand on arrive quand on
regarde les endroits qui peuvent être
dangereux pour lui et là où il faut
préserver parce que
après nous on les laisse libres et on
surveille on préconise les endroits où
on voit que ça pourrait être dangereux
il pourrait passer
donc on protège tout comme catherine la
spa appelle à ne pas laisser ces animaux
cet été allez viens mon grison s'est
aggravée par la commune en plein mois de
mai quel trois mois tu peux me faire ça
n'a pas gâché baraka pourquoi me sortir
du refuge pour faire ça un an après
cette lumière c'est la même que la
dernière fois allez bon débarras tient
chaque année en france ce sont cent
mille chats et chiens qui sont
abandonnés avec un pic pendant la
période estivale
malgré les solutions et voilà voguer
vous y ferez moteur premières vacances à
introd vient me voir via charles ta
valise te plaît c'est paradis lui dire
que j'avais peur de départs en vacances
[Musique]